c'est un procès très médiatisé qui se
voulait historique et qui au final a
tourné court mercredi prochain donald
trump eux devrait être acquittée sans
grande surprise par le sénat américain
lancé en septembre dernier par la
chambre des représentants
cette procédure de destitution a très
vite tourné à la course d'obstacles pour
les démocrates
l'espoir de réunir la majorité des deux
tiers des 100 sénateurs requis par la
constitution pour démettre le président
s'est éloigné au fil des jours avec 47
sièges les démocrates ne sont pas
parvenus à obtenir une majorité simple
celle là même qu'il aurait permis
d'obtenir la convocation de témoins
supplémentaires
pourtant durant ces derniers mois
l'espoir semblait revenir dans le camp
des démocrates
grâce notamment aux fuites du livre de
mémoire de john bolton l'ex conseiller
de la trump qui aurait fait hésiter
quelques sénateurs républicains malgré
le soutien de suzanne collins et de mitt
romney deux sénateurs modérés à la
requête des camps démocrates la chambre
haute a racheté in extremis par
cinquante et une voix contre 49 cette
demande
un coup dur pour l'opposition est un
soulagement pour les proches de donald
trump
c'est une grande tragédie les américains
se souviendront de ce jour où le sénat
s'est détourné de la vérité
je suis très heureux que le sénat ait
rejeté la demande des démocrates
d'appeler des témoins supplémentaires
après que la chambre ait choisi de ne
pas le faire comme je les dis il ne
s'agit pas d'une infraction
imprescriptible et les témoins
recherchés par les représentants de la
chambre était à leur disposition un
épisode qui n'a jamais vraiment inquiété
le locataire de la maison blanche déjà
dans les starting blocks pour la
présidentielle de 2000 20 donald trump
prononcera son discours sur l'état de
l'union mardi soir devant le congrès la
veille du jugement qui mettra fin à ce
procès un procès qui semble avoir
renforcé le président et remobiliser son
camp alors que commencent les primaires
de la présidentielle
[Musique]